Strip away all the fierce makeup, battle-coiffed
hairstyles, and intricate tattoos, and the
Norse warriors on Vikings are just like the
rest of us...if we were all muscular and ridiculously
good looking, anyway.
Sure, their characters look like they'd fit
right into the Viking Age of history, but
here's what these 21st-century actors look
like in real life.
Travis Fimmel
Though he doesn't sport Ragnar's shaved head
and ZZ Top beard in real life, Travis Fimmel
still looks pretty Vikingly, with a blonde
beard and striking blue eyes.
The actor and model doesn't actually hail
from the northlands of Scandinavia, though.
Rather, he comes from down under, and was
raised on his family's farm in Australia.
Fimmel is set to write and produce a scripted
anthology series for the History Channel detailing
the stories of some of history's biggest anti-heroes,
and is set to star as the gunslingin' Wyatt
Earp on the new series' first episode.
Katheryn Winnick
It's easy to argue that Katheryn Winnick is
the most iconically Viking-looking actor on
the entire show, even if she doesn't really
hail from Scandinavia—she's actually Canadian.
And Winnick doesn't only kick ass on TV.
The actress has been training in martial arts
since childhood, and boasts some serious credentials.
Winnick told StarPulse:
"I got into my first [martial arts] school
when I was 16.
I have a 3rd degree black belt in Tae Kwon
Do and a 2nd degree black belt in Karate."
She's also a licensed bodyguard and self-defense
instructor.
So don't mess with Earl Ingstad.
Alexander Ludwig
Over the course of the show's run, Vikings
fans have watched Ragnar Lothbrok's firstborn
son grow up from a momma's boy to a bear-killing
warrior.
As his character has aged, we've seen actor
Alexander Ludwig's look transition from short
hair and and a peach fuzz beard to a shaved
head with one extra-long, braided ponytail.
In real life, Ludwig keeps a beard going,
though he doesn't walk around California with
a waist-long Viking ponytail.
Though Ludwig obviously didn't play the child
version of Björn in the show, he has been
acting since he was a child.
Most notably, Ludwig took home an MTV Movie
Award for Best Fight thanks to his role as
Cato in The Hunger Games.
Clive Standen
Rollo is one of the most fearsome Vikings
on the show, and he always looked the part,
with long, dark hair and a bushy beard.
In real life, however, Clive Standen looks
less ferocious, as he tends to stay sharp
with short, tidy hair and a finely-trimmed
beard.
But don't let that clean-shaven appearance
fool you.
The actor has been riding horses, jousting
and sword fighting since childhood, and is
also a Muay Thai expert — meaning you wouldn't
want to challenge Standen on any battlefield,
Viking or not.
Gustaf Skarsgård
As his name implies, Gustaf Skarsgård is
one of Vikings' only true Scandinavians, though
he looks a lot less fearsome in real life.
While Flóki is famous for sporting a beard
and that iconic crying makeup, Skarsgård
stays clean-shaven and professional, just
like the rest of his actor-filled family.
It's a big family, too.
His father, Stellan Skarsgård, is easily
the most famous of the family, having appeared
in Good Will Hunting, the Pirates of the Caribbean
franchise, The Girl With the Dragon Tattoo,
and the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
You may also know Gustaf's brother, Alexander
Skarsgård, for his roles as Eric Northman
in HBO's long-running series True Blood and
the title character in The Legend of Tarzan.
And chances are, you know his other brother,
Bill, thanks to his performance as Pennywise
in Stephen King's It.
That's one seriously prolific family.
Alyssa Sutherland
In the role of Queen Aslaug, Alyssa Sutherland
can bewitch even a Viking king with her stunning
looks — a trait to be expected in a famous,
real-life fashion model.
Sutherland got her modeling start when Cadbury
revived its iconic "Flake Girl" advertising
campaign.
She's since been featured in campaigns for
such brands as Calvin Klein and Chanel , among
others.
Not many models make the successful transition
to acting like Sutherland already has, so
we'll have to wait and see if this Vikings
star lands more prime roles in the future.
Maude Hirst
With her long blonde hair and kind face, Maude
Hirst was a perfect casting choice for Helga,
the wife of Flóki, though she undoubtedly
had some help.
Her father is Michael Hirst, the writer and
producer of Elizabeth, The Tudors and Vikings.
Hirst doesn't credit her father for getting
her into the acting biz, though.
She told View of the Arts:
"I was always creative, I didn't grow up much
with my father.
I was raised by my mum who is an artist and
that's what probably influenced my creativity."
While there's no doubt Hirst deserves the
role of Helga, it certainly never hurts to
have your father as the show's producer.
Linus Roache
Give him a crown, and Linus Roache looks almost
identical to King Ecbert in real life.
Aside from Vikings, most television viewers
probably know him best as Michael Cutter in
the long-running crime drama Law & Order.
On top of all that, Roache has also made quite
a few big screen appearances, with roles in
Priest, Batman Begins, and The Chronicles
of Riddick, among others.
Moe Dunford
Though he plays the English Prince Aethelwulf
in Vikings, actor Moe Dunford is actually
Irish — a fact slightly masked by the show's
producers, who've given the character dark
brown hair rather than Dunford's natural red.
Irish audiences, however, are certainly inclined
to recognize Dunford as the actor who played
Patrick Fitzgerald in Patrick's Day — an
award-winning Irish drama centered around
a 26-year-old schizophrenic and his St. Patrick's
Day disappearance in Dublin.
Jennie Jacques
Take Vikings' Judith out of her medieval princess
garb and stick her in some 21st-century clothes,
and you have actress Jennie Jacques.
Besides a wardrobe change and some makeup,
very little seems to be done to actually change
Jacques' appearance for the show.
Jacques is no stranger to the historical drama.
Fans may recognize the actress from her other
major role as Annie Miller in the BBC series
Desperate Romantics.
She's also an advocate for epilepsy awareness
and recently completed an open water swim
and a Spartan Sprint to raise money for the
Epilepsy Society.
Alex Andersen
Like his character Ivar the Boneless, Alex
Andersen almost never sports a beard.
Unlike his character, however, he looks a
lot less scary in real life.
And as you probably guessed, Andersen's legs
work just fine.
Aside from Vikings, Andersen also appeared
in the Danish drama A War, which received
a nomination for the Best Foreign Language
Film at the 88th Academy Awards.
John Kavanagh
You probably won't recognize Vikings' The
Seer from anywhere, considering the blind
oracle is covered in an extensive amount of
makeup, has no eyes, and is most frequently
portrayed in his dark hut.
John Kavanagh obviously doesn't look grotesque
in real life, which may be why you missed
the fact that he also played the Pope in a
Season 4 episode.
Now that you know what he looks like, you
might recognize Kavanagh from The Tudors,
as well as minor roles in bigger films like
The Black Dahlia and Braveheart.
Whether or not Kavanagh enjoys having his
palm regularly licked by Vikings' stars, however,
is best left to speculation.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!